Lauren Michaels this is a quote from
Lauren Michaels he called uh you Jim
Downey the best political humorist
alive um well that was before the birth
three years ago of a hilarious
child ogy
Johnson um well just but I've seen the
kid
stuff uh I uh yeah you're so principled
and you're right now um there's so much
there's so much political comedy now
which is Wailing one way or the other
and I find that it's just a uh I don't
know it doesn't feel to me like a
satisfying time to be a comedy writer if
you're trying to do politics because
there's there's so much that's
just there's a temptation to enrage the
audience I mean you know I mean I don't
I mean personally I you know I'm I just
Lo Trump as a human being and
and but it doesn't mean
that every just just attacking him is
funny there are interesting ways to
attack him you know I always like John
meany's thing about there's a horse
loose in the hospital that I mean just a
sort of an interesting melany had a
great run about Trump as president was
like there's a horse loose in a hospital
and just how odd that was and uh it was
a metaphor was a great metaphor for for
Trump being president and what I loved
about it was it captured the absurdity
of it all but it did it in this way that
there was no bile it was and and it's
very hard you need to sometimes it was
purely comedic which I loved so let's
just end this by saying that John meany
is better than anyone we know is that
the point you were trying to make he's
very good very funny man MH uh he when
when melany first came to the show as a
writer um you were talking about like my
you know I like to sort of identify
people and I didn't I didn't find meryon
but I was walking
through and this is really about melenia
not me but I was walking through the
studio and it by the end of my career I
was you know I was like you know 60
years old and I I um you know I I
just you know I was aware of of the age
gap between me and the and having once
been the very youngest writer I was now
massively the oldest writer and um so I
didn't I didn't hang out I didn't do the
late night things I wrote from home like
you know I I live in Upstate New York
near Cooperstown and so I I would be at
home Sunday Monday Tuesday and then I'd
write my piece and i' I dictate I always
dictate my pieces because I they're you
know they have to be spoken and they
have to be speakable and they have to be
they're going to be heard and not read
and so you need to in in when I'm
dictating them I'm changing them go wait
a minute hang on I'm changing you know
and anyway so they they have it a read
through and then I'm I'm told if it's in
or not and if it's in I drive down to
New York and anyway so I was in the
studio on Saturday and I don't even I'm
not even sure i' met melan it was like
the second show and I'm walking through
the studio and I'm and they're
rehearsing one of his P he had a piece
on I think it was like
his his second show and he had a this
this this hilarious piece on and there's
a great sort of it was a um the host was
um uh Tim McGraw and and he who is a
really good actor very funny guy and he
it was like a a country kind of um it
was like a a a show where he does like
practical jokes but he's such a a
soft-hearted s he keeps like apologizing
for it's hard to explain you have to see
the but and I heard it and I know this
makes me sound like an arrogant
but it reminded me of that there was a
story about Ted
Williams um when Hank Aaron was a rookie
Ted Williams is playing uh he was
somehow involved in the I didn't know
they had inter league games or anything
but but um Hank Aaron is is is warming
up and Ted Williams is sitting in the
Dugout and here's from the way the ball
is coming off Hank Aaron's bat that he's
never heard that before and he storms
out there go who's who was just taking
batting practice and it was Hank Aon and
and Ted Williams like and I sort of had
that it was akin to that I'm not
comparing myself to Ted Williams no I am
comparing John mean to Hank Aaron though
he's a lot like hanar but I I'm saying
that I walk into the studio and I hear
this and I
go that's a new writer that's a new we
don't that's not a writer I know yeah
yeah that's we have a new writer or a
guest writer because
that that wasn't that's not and I'm
listening to the piece and I go that was
not written by a writer who's work on so
and I was right I was right it turned
out it was it was um John and he went on
to write a lot of great
stuff and then he's trying stand up
but whatever he's Young he's young he'll
get it he'll get it he will get it hang
in there
sir